on va rester dans cette perspective
européenne et pour parler des élections
mais cette fois ci du côté français
benoît hamon qu'est le chef de file du
mouvement générations point s je pense
que veut dire quoi s mais c'est
important dans le futur répéter
génération point s ils étaient ils
étaient ce matin chez nos confrères de
rtl et alors c'est qu'il ya une
multitude de listes de gauche 1 pour
l'instant il ya génération point ce
temps qu'il ya europe ecologie les verts
il ya la france insoumise
il ya le parti socialiste même si l'on
pourra encore de tête de liste il ya le
parti communiste et puis il ya place
publique
le mouvement fondé par raphaël
glucksmann comme tout ça ça fait du
monde et bien benoît hamon il propose un
truc original il dit mais si on se
décider avant en faisant une élection
entre nous regardez ce que ça donne le
mode de scrutin que je vais proposer il
a déjà été expérimentée ailleurs qu'en
france il est original
il est d'une incroyable modernité et
surtout il a un mérite il rase o
imaginons que demain nous ayons une
dizaine de listes de gauche écologistes
qu'ils soient soumis au vote des
citoyens de gauche et des écologistes
qui souhaiteraient y participer
bien nous leur proposerons ce qu'on
appelle un vote préférentiel de donner
un tiercé la liste qu'il préfère la
liste en 2d et la liste en troisième
alors je vois que ça vous fait rire gêné
brabham comme ci ou ça vous paraître
c'est pas sérieux
non et c'est le grand retour de ce qui
nous divise et moins important que ce
qui nous rassemble
c'est ça a du sens on a une
constellation de micro mouvement à
gauche qui qui risque de faire un score
catastrophique donc moi je trouve que
c'est une démarche qui a du sens après
c'est un appel général on sait très bien
que tout le monde va pas y répondre mais
clairement il faut espérer pour eux que
le parti socialiste se joignent à
génération point est ce parce que je
vois pas vraiment la différence entre
les deux bon après il faudrait pas que
ça attendent non plus à devenir l'armée
mexicaine de gauche parce que je vois
pas non plus qui rassemble le parti
socialiste et le parti de mélenchon
s'est pas forcément très clair car mais
qu'est ce que veut faire benoît hamon en
fait il faut organiser une primaire ça
un peu l'idée c'est que les électeurs
qui se reconnaissent de gauche
choisissent la liste mais pour ça il ya
un truc qui s'appelle élections non
pourquoi il pu faire ça avant les
européens si vous avez compris ce qui
s'est mal exprimé
c'est vraiment un truc de gauchistes
deviens pro grand rien au système
électoral qui l'a mis en place non mais
c'est vrai c'est ok parce que oui je
n'en doute pas je suis d'accord à gauche
c'est vraiment lui déplaît non mais
alors on voit bien pourquoi benoît hamon
faire ça vous évoquez la primaire c'est
exactement ça c'est à dire que lui ça
lui a réussi d'avoir une mobilisation de
la gauche
le problème qu'on peut évoquer c'est
deux choses 1 face à lui aussi il a fait
ça ira 6% il a éliminé manuel valls
ensuite ça lui a pas réussi comme quoi
ce n'est absolument pas la garantie pour
l'élection pour les élections
européennes
2 il n'y a aucune garantie de respect
non plus des scrutins puisque on a vu
qu'un certain nombre de participants à
la primaire de la gauche n'ont pas
respecté leur propre signature et ont
choisi de soutenir un autre candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
donc bon courage et troisièmement on a
bien vu quand même qui avait alors le
modem manipulation est peut-être un peu
fort mais qu'il y avait des des pans
entiers de d'électeur ou de militants de
la france insoumise qui sont venus
participer à cette primaire non pas pour
voter pour benoît hamon mais pour emilie
mines et manuel valls
donc on voit bien que tout ça était
faussé et là on comprend pas très bien
comment lui va faire le tri entre les
électeurs de sa votation citoyenne
donc voyez tout ça est un peu compliqué
et il faut juste rappeler quand même que
place publique a essayé elle de faire un
effort de réglisse man c'est un
mouvement de gauche lancé par des
intellectuels
or voilà on repartira file luxe mme anne
claire nouvian et à l'économie
thomas marché si je me trompe pas en
disant on essaye de rassembler tout le
monde
benoît hamon n'y est pas allé et après
il dit oui ça marche pas donc j'appelle
les hectares il ya une contradiction est
ce que vous y comprenez quelque chose
anthony cortese n'ont pas grand chose
mais je trouve ça formidable justement
ces grains cirque parce que voilà on
sort d'un mouvement populaire les gillet
jeu où on retrouve quelque part a le le
socle de la gorge le socle historique
avec des ouvriers ils sont gonflés gilet
jaune pour moi c'était un mouvement de
gauche et justement les les
revendications d'un gilet jaune le
disent ils sont pour plus de justice
fiscale ils ont pour plus de protection
plus de service public
et là on a la gauche qui comme réponse
sort une manoeuvres d'appareil
moi j'arrive pas à comprendre cette
stratégie et en plus à cette à ce côté
loufoque et i7 cette démarche parce
qu'on voyait d'un échec total parce que
la seule réponse positive à l'appel de
mouvements c'est le ps qui ne
comprennent plus rien et places
publiques qui est une construction
médiatique qui ne m'arrive pas à
comprendre le poids cantona place
publique
aujourd'hui dans le paysage politique
français
donc donc voilà le thème pour moi c'est
un cirque complètement un tragique
en fait c'est quelque part la preuve que
la la gauche a renoncé à changer la vie
mais voilà c'est trouver une une
existence dans le fait de vouloir sauver
la gauche mais uniquement ça alors on
vous a posé la question sur twitter sur
le hashtag figaro là il va acheter un
point de vue trouvez vous que la
votation citoyenne proposé par benoît
hamon pour rassembler la gauche est une
bonne idée
et bien pas tout à fait puisque 74%
d'entre vous considérez que non et clôt
rom dit non ce n'est pas une bonne idée
gauche comme droite doivent complètement
mourir afin de pouvoir renaître de leurs
cendres avec de nouvelles idées de
nouvelles têtes
il est de toute façon trop tôt pour une
alliance à gauche nicole pose la
question en la gauche existe-t-elle
encore et brownie taux considéré que les
députés européens en ayant de toute
façon aucun pouvoir sur les institutions
la plupart des programmes sont
fantaisistes
alors tout cas ce qui est certain c'est
que l'accueil de la proposition de
benoît hamon a et plutôt frais
écoutez par exemple la réaction de
yannick jadot c'est la tête de liste
europe écologie les verts aux
européennes donc on lui dit ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec cette proposition de
benoît hamon est en fait il répond il
répond non le sujet se sont pas les egos
et la cohérence politique
et puis ce qu'on nous propose c'est
d'être en compétition interne de faire
une sorte de congrès socialiste très
large associant toutes les citoyens au
moment où il faut faire campagne pour
l'europe
ok mais au delà de l'ironie qu'est-ce
qui se passe enfin pourquoi est-ce-que
pourquoi est ce que la gauche c'est
comme ça aussi atomisé la vérité c'est
qu'entre yannick jadot et benoît hamon
il n'y a pas grand chose et plutôt que
de faire de mauvais scores pourquoi ils
se mettent pas ensemble vous avez une
explication à cette division parce que
tout simplement c'est le reliquat
d'amener de vie politique où les partis
politiques avaient des sinécures grâce
aux élections et en particulier les
élections européennes permettait je
dirais grâce au scrutin proportionnel
d'obtenir un certain nombre d'élus et
qu' ils veulent tous essayé d'avoir une
petite part du gâteau le problème c'est
que là ce sont les en face de liste qui
ne sont peut-être même pas sûr de faire
3 % donc d'avoir le remboursement des
frais et puis de n'aime pas sûr de faire
5 % pour avoir des élus je crois qu'il
faut vraiment qu'ils se posent la
question de savoir si leur survie est
plus importante que effectivement leur
leurs querelles d'ego sincèrement moi je
les théorisé c'est avait eu la
gentillesse y faire allusion tout à
l'heure c'est ce que j'appelle le
mouvement dextrogyre c'est à dire que la
pression idéologique elle ne doit plus
par la gauche du spectre politique et
désormais par la droite la gauche
socialiste elle est quasiment
aujourd'hui inexistante ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'il n'ya pas une force
d'inertie qu'il n'ya pas encore générer
une pression fiscale on parlera tout à
l'heure encore très forte
mais la pression idéologique elle ne
vient plus de la part des collectivistes
il y en a plus de véritables collective
c'est donc par conséquent on a un
personnel politique qui existe toujours
mais qui n'a quasiment plus d'électeurs
donc évidemment il faut qu'ils se
partagent un gâteau qui est
de plus en plus de plus en plus
restreint bon alors explique armelle
cette espèce de ce qui ressemble
quand-même milliards il faut pas
préjuger du résultat des élections mais
à une forme de suicide collectif
en tout cas une démarche qui traînent
pas très constructive ça s'explique
exactement ce que dit guillaume bernard
c'est à dire que le problème c'est que
il n'arrive pas à dépasser un seuil qui
va leur permettre d'exister
politiquement et médiatiquement
toutes ces listes en séparément fonds 3
5 6% et donc on comprend bien pourquoi
vous l'avez rappelé vient du pradel ni
jean-luc mélenchon ni yannick jadot ne
vont aller dans cet ensemble parce que
quand vous êtes fort et que vous peser
vous n'avez pas intérêt à avoir un
boulet à côté de vous ou chez vous qui
vient un peu vous laisse t le problème
c'est qu'on le sait très bien les
élections européennes ne ne construisent
pas quelque chose dans la vie politique
nationale
chevènement pasqua d'ailleurs les verts
l'ont appris à leurs dépends villiers
l'ont appris à leurs dépens il est très
bon score des élections européennes ça
n'a rien construit derrière sur une
élection européenne
en revanche ça peut détruire des
carrières politiques et alain pour le
coup michel rocard peux vous en parler
nicolas sarkozy en 99 ça va pas détruit
mais celle-là freiner et il s'en
souvient encore et là on se voit très
bien que si le parti socialiste y va
tout seul
il ya un vrai danger à la fois financier
et politique s'ils se font en moins de 3
et au moins 2 5
même chose pour benoît hamon
donc c'est l'enjeu pour eux c'est un
enjeu de survie politique
alors au diable et un nouvel an selon
les sondages donc europe ecologie les
verts et la france insoumise pour à peu
près jeu égal à 8 % d'intentions de vote
pour les européennes le parti socialiste
et à 6% génération point est ce donc le
parti de benoît hamon est à 4%
le parti communiste à 2% et places
publiques pour l'instant on n'a pas
encore été n'a pas encore été testée est
ce que vous croyez anthony cortese que
celui qui peut sortir vainqueurs de
cette ce désordre
c'est jean luc mélenchon en tout cas son
parti puisqu'elle même des pâtés de
liste parce que à la fin c'est celui qui
crie le plus fort qu'on va entendre le
mieux depuis quelque part ce serait ce
serait la suite logique quelque part
voilà j'ai lu comme une chance et c'est
le seul qui n'a pas connu d'échec
cuisant
dernières élections c'est le seul cas qu
apporter quelque part ce que porter le
gilet jaune c'est à dire 1 s'ouvre
souverainistes de gauche quelque part
donc je pense que c'est le seul qui en
tout cas ne sortira pas complètement
perdant lors de la dire qu'il en soit
gagnant je ne suis pas sûr mais c'est
bien ce ne sera pas complètement perdant
pour il n'y a pas de tête de liste
socialiste mais il n'arrive pas à
trouver gallisa expatriés il ya ségolène
royal qui avait été approchée qui était
d'ailleurs assez partante mais avec une
condition qu'ils étaient justement
est-ce qu'ils essayent de faire benoît
hamon mais elle a essayé de le faire
avec les dirigeants rassemblés tout le
monde de yannick jadot
jusqu'à alors pas mélenchon mais place
publique le problème c'est qu'ils annick
jadot a repositionné l'écologie sur un 1
comment dire sur l'absence de clivage
droite gauche
il est sur le ni droite ni gauche donc
il fait revenir les écolos à l'époque
devait jetèrent mais du coup qui
bloquent complètement la possibilité
d'un rassemblement à gauche est ce que
révèle la différence est que
effectivement wechter n'était pas
nécessairement de gauche alors qu'il ya
déjà dos lui les mais il a bien compris
que
il ya plus devoir acquérir et ailleurs
que si la gauche on additionne tous les
scores ils font 25 points mais s'est
déversée les 25% qu'on a eu à la
présidentielle 25% c'est ce que faisait
à lui tout seul à lui tout seul le parti
communiste dans les années 70 avant que
mitterrand ne réussisse à le siphonner
donc c'est bien le signe qui évidemment
on a là une disparition du spectre
politique et par conséquent le
libéralisme qui avait glissé à droite
est en train de glisser à gauche du
spectre police c'est aussi ça montre
aussi les jeunes est probable que le
maquereau nice barbe fini de produire
ses effets c'est qu'effectivement il il
détruit tout les tous les partis
politiques traditionnels quand il disait
ben voilà avec moi il ya une nouvelle
offre et les autres offres politiques ne
sont plus pertinents et celle
d'évitement de la gauche et rappelons
quand même qu'il ya encore un certain
nombre de gens ayant une sensibilité de
gauche au sein de la république en
marche
oui on a besoin je vois anticasseurs
exactement mais oui ça n'a pas fini de
produire ses effets alors surtout à
droite je pense plutôt qu'à gauche
c'est un avis personnel la droite doit
prendre en considération le fait à
partir du moment où macron est toujours
présent même s'il baisse dans les
sondages
il n'empêche que il son positionnement
central oblige à la recomposition du
spectre politique disparition de la
gauche et la droite va connaître elle
aussi des difficultés
vous vous soyez favorable à une votation
citoyenne à droite avant l'élection
européenne
je suis favorable pour ma part à ce
qu'il y ait une recomposition du spectre
politique par la base d'accords donc mal
forcément par ailleurs si pourri pour
essayer un sens vous regardez nicolas
dupont aignan ils rassembleront
nationale il a quand même beaucoup plus
de choses qui les rassemble bien sûr et
quand vous voyez françois-xavier belhani
sur la liste et l'air et jean et jean
frédéric poisson sur la liste d'alliance
avec nba que vont faire les cathos lyon
défie ils vont diviser vont couper leur
bulletin en deux voilà jean frédéric
poisson qui est le patron du parti
chrétien démocrate
on va parler des impôts
sujet qui est toujours chère à nos
dirigeants on a eu un peu la frousse en
sept semaines passent